fond du story or memory with screech
dustin diamond
you know we we were close when we were
doing the show and then all of us went
our own way so
there were many many years where
we weren't in each other's lives um but
i just remember
laughing a lot with dustin he was the
goofiest [ __ ] you ever could
get
in the same room with he made these
choices that were ju
choices that only he could make on on
screen he was really good he was a very
talented actor
um at a very young age um but we we had
a lot of good times and and uh just
remember a lot of laughter with him and
playing video games i remember playing a
lot of video games with the guy too and
his dad would just sit in his room and
he had like a neogeo
uh back when that was like the premiere
gaming platform
and uh he was the coolest kid
geo
my god i mean were was it tough when you
heard about the loss did you feel like
he was just kind of
it was just shocking to you were you
were you shocked or did you know about
it
i was totally shocked because the year
before i had seen him at a comic-con and
we were next to each other and
you know
he never said a word about his health
and then to find out that he died so
quickly
um without any of us really knowing what
was going on that that was shocking and
really sad that he didn't
he he didn't uh
you know connect with us a little bit
more before his passing um i don't i
don't think it's his fault i just think
that maybe he thought things were going
to be better or
um
[Music]
yeah exactly but
it was shocking it was very sad and and
uh
uh i mean jesus christ he was only 42 or
so
that's unbelievable